I sometimes wonder with these folks
which stage of the ritualistic
self-mutilation exercise are we in at
this point and
actually you know on the war room we
talk a lot about China and as I assess
these Chinese capabilities that we allow
into our country like the Balloon Mania
I never really got because we got what
one in every four Americans with tick
tock on their phone we've got a Chinese
surveillance equipment at almost every
U.S Port where they are able to get
signals Intelligence on the entire
supply chain of the United States we
have Rural America being connected by
Chinese technology we have U.S police
stations flying Chinese drones and we're
going to get worked up over like 1950s
technology
right everyone could see it so it was a
sigh I came on the War Room the day
after and said I thought that was a
total psya but a serious country would
not do these things